I went about it a very strange way
because I never set my I quite liked I
mean I liked acting at school I was
enchanting as the White Rabbit in Alice
in Wonderland I think I still have the
costume I slip into it sometimes I did
some acting when I was in university as
I've sort of you know in the drama
society there but it was never gonna be
I never thought it would be my career
and then oddly enough I made a film an
amateur film at Oxford when I was there
some guy got together a little bit of
money the help of John Schlesinger whose
portrait is just outside this room and
and we shot that film and really it was
pretty pretentious but agents came up to
me right here a BAFTA in nineteen summer
of 1982 and it had a screening and said
that you want to be an actor and I said
no thank you very much and then I went
home and I was thinking of because I was
due to go off and do another degree
somewhere else and I suddenly thought
actually I need money so I rang up the
agents I said alright I've been active
for a year and I was so bad frankly that
I I thought I better do another job
another acting job to prove I'm not as
bad as I was in the first one and that
process has gone out gone on for 36
years what do I look for in a part while
I probably I've been slightly different
in my approach and then some other
actors some other of my contemporaries
in that I think they perhaps right they
have always just gone for what's the
most interesting part and I have always
gone for is this an entertaining piece
of work will anyone actually want to see
this in our slightly different ways of
going about things and it's just that I
can't see the point of acting unless
it's to entertain people and some people
can see the point of it you get an
inkling when you read the script and
that's the basis on which you say yes or
no you think can I will I ever get there
can I
and I got an idea where I might go to
get this character and you need that you
cling to that and then you say yes and
do your deal and then you panic and
think can I really do it and you have to
I find try and trust yourself and that
happens quite slowly you know you just
got to go about it methodically and keep
reading the script and making notes
particularly about biography I don't
write quite long biographies of the
character they get longer and longer and
longer and and at some point things
start to happen you know you suddenly
find you've got the voice you've got the
walk or something they do with their
hands or um and a costume fitting is
massively important I find you know with
film there's really no rehearsal if
you're lucky if you get a moment round a
table in the week before you start
shooting and suddenly you think of
Christ they're gonna do that okay all I
see or worse you start to you know
rehearse slightly you start to say some
lines as your character and you see
everyone looking nervous and then the
director says yeah yeah you know III
didn't see him having that voice and
then you have to rethink everything with
a few days to go I sound like such a
terrible old love you but the dream is
that you can trust them if they're good
and if they're not in a panic and and
with film it's particularly important
that people aren't in a panic and quite
often I am and it really the whole of
film acting is about how to avoid panic
and and try and leave as relaxed as you
can and if you if you're too relaxed
actors together both quite comfortable
in the way you're playing apart you can
go into the scene with no preconceived
idea and just see where it takes you see
what you do and react to that and it's a
lovely feeling because everything's then
fresh the way you do your lines
completely fresh because it's based on
what you just did and the camera I've
learnt tends to love anything that's
fresh not which invented in that moment
and that's very often the take that ends
up in the film whereas when you just
repeating the way you'd practiced it for
months in the bathroom mirror
that tends to be a bit dead well
directors I don't know I mean I've
worked with every kind of extreme I've
worked with incredibly hands-on micro
managing directors like Roman Polanski
you know my god you've got to say like
this you've got to pick up the coffee
cup like this I want you to hold it like
that
and I've worked with you know Stephen
Frears now twice who very rarely says
anything but seemed very good to me no
let's move on I suppose you just have to
adapt I personally quite like a minimal
approach just just a lot of praise that
was fabulous darling that's all I need
it's confidence really well they're all
challenged every jobs been and I'm
racked with anxiety but I have to say
having signed up to do Florence Foster
Jenkins in the knowledge that I was
going to be playing opposite Meryl
Streep you can't get much more
frightening than that and also there was
a long delay between signing up and
actually starting I think it was like 12
months or something
that's a long time to be frightened so
that was yeah that was extremely
frightening day one of that you know the
technology of filmmaking is hasn't
changed very much in a hundred years and
it's still damn slow so you know as you
know you film maybe two pages of script
a day a little bit more of his
television but that's basically you're
making two minutes of the film in 12 or
14 hour day so there's an incredible
element of tedium and this is what
people always find when they visit the
set you know say well can I come visit
you on the set and you say I don't think
you're gonna want to they say yeah I
want I want to and they come and they
practically faint with boredom because
it's just you know that's 16 different
angles and so many takes all are the
same thing so you're fighting boredom
and fear because in that 12 hour day you
might be in close-up once or twice and
you know that's the key moment for you
as an actor and it's just awful when
they say and now he were going to set up
for your close-up will be about an hour
back to your trailer and you just sit
there sweating and you come back on a
set and it's all pointing at you
everyone's pointing at you and you know
especially when I was making those big
Hollywood films all the money is
pointing at you and it's just the
pressures unbearable
one thing I did I'm glad I made some
American films because it was
interesting watching American actors
they're much less reverent in terms of
the script than British actors they
especially in comedies they endlessly
improvising doing different things they
don't really care too much what was in
the script they don't care too much
about where they've been told to stand
and I think that's very useful and
people should should do more of that but
in British films because it comes back
to my thing about freshness really the
camera loves fresh anything new and it
hasn't been pre rehearsed
[Music]
you
[Music]